benvenuti nuovissimo veda come avrete
intuito dal titolo oggi vi farò vedere
dei regali che ho ricevuto quindi è per
me come se fosse un natale in anticipo
infatti ormai lo saprete chi mi segue lo
sa
ogni tanto sephora mi invia tutte le
novità i nuovi prodotti e io solitamente
ve ne faccio vedere nelle storie
instagram visto che ogni volta che vi
faccio vedere le storie instagram
mi dite ma perché non ci fai un video
top
partiamo subito io partirei con questo
fantastico cofanetto di to face con
questo albero di natale costituito da
valente un packaging fantastico fiabesco
wow
vi faccio vedere le palette allora ci
sono questi plus credo siano si lascia e
fard tonalità molto calde pescate rosa e
questa è la punta dell'albero poi nella
seconda palette è costituita da ombretti
di tonalità news calde shimmer in sé e
poi l'ultima la terza palette e tra
l'altro la base dell'albero comunque
piccola base oro apriamola insieme è
sempre di ombretti c'è anche un
melanzana c'è anche un petrolio e ci
sono questi tre ombretti shimmer tra cui
un verde abete fantastico lo utilizzerò
per i make up natalizi questo è the
trade and sex che è una scala da fuoco è
incollato e incollato io adoro questo
questo primo cofanetto è secondo me la
vita dottor charles allora chica per
christmas jungle
ovviamente non so cosa siano mandiamole
giorno insieme allora trattamento
correttivo della pigmentazione all'erba
di kike ecco perché c'era la tigre sulla
confezione erba di tigre ma cosa sarà
[Musica]
insieme no perché voi non potete sa di
erba ma indovinate un po non sa di tigre
[Musica]
vi ricorda qualcosa della mia infanzia
il re leone vabbè andiamo avanti le
proprie farò sapere perché così è un po
affrettata la conclusione continuiamo
con un cofanetto di make up for ever non
si apre city race consente quando c'è
questa tu tiri e si apre con eto'o ma
non si apre ha fatto crack è incollato a
c'è lo scotch è infatti una volta che
togli lo scotch si apre come potete
vedere top allora matita occhi e labbra
sembra un color mattone poi rossetto la
mia moto
ovviamente dello stesso colore poi
questa cipria fissante super carina da
viaggio che mi serviva perché tutti gli
amici prefissati sono grosse così e nel
2t casa viaggio diciamo che ingombrano
parecchio e poi qua avremo secondo me la
esatto la base lisciante il primer make
up for ever comuni con benché utilizzo
che mi piace un sacco
proseguiamo a questo è un gufo un ufo ma
non è finita qui perché è un gufo che si
illumina di notte una lampada è anche
questo e molto nel mood perché le
stelline e oro bianco e oro e di sephora
e lo accenderò nell'angolino dove farò
l'albero chiaramente ci sarà anche la
postazione del gufo che non abbiamo
ancora capito se portafortuna o meno io
sapevo che portava fortuna non sapevi
che ho fatto perché ho sentito gente mi
diceva che portava sfortuna se ti guardo
un buon futuro
guardami si sta agli occhi chiusi però
cavolo l'hanno fatto apposta già questa
qui invece di questo qua con sciocchetti
fluo non può saperlo
comunque faccio vuole così carina va beh
vediamo se dice cosa c'è dentro versione
mignon
cielo questo è uno spreco si spruzza sui
cuscini sulle lenzuola e aiuta a
rilassarsi a entrare nel mood notturno e
a dormire in maniera beata e questo di
face ski che io adoro
praticamente è una fiala di acido
ialuronico puro
voi sapete tutti benefici dell'acido
ialuronico riguardo le sai quali sono o
sono una capra idratante ti fa sembrare
più giovane più bella combatte i
radicali liberi questo lo sapevano
antiossidante rimpolpante chiaramente
grazie per l'aiuto dalla regia perché di
tutto lo metti effetto lifting
fantastico
questo è uno di quelli che utilizzerò
per primo di questi prodotti perché è da
una vita e voglio provarlo vi farò
sapere
a quando pescate 2 prendiamo questa a
d'oro cioè che si chiama once upon a
palette volo fard in polvere per il viso
ombretti e terra di sephora ovviamente
oddio l'abbiamo insieme
no no ro ro ro ro
le palette comunque le palette sono la
gioia di noi donne ci piace c'è questa
tinta labbra rosso fuoco
questo immagino che siano appunto le
ciprie e le polveri per il viso ombretti
anche qui ritroviamo una tonalità di due
tonalità di verde un verde militare e un
verde smeraldo un verde jasmine di
aladino molto molto carino ma
continuiamo perché non etnica
questa è la crema da giorno
ringiovanente allora leggiamo 23 dritte
è sempre in francese quindi dovrò
tradurre la formula si ispira a una
prescrizione ancestrale di un
manoscritto della medicina cinese cioè
ragazzi
roba d'altri tempi questa formula si
basa su l'incapsulamento dei principi
attivi che permette un'assimilazione
continua per la pelle appena tradotto
dal francese ragazzi però seguiamo oddio
io amo becca becca una marca che mi fa
impazzire shimmer in skin per sector
press
oro tutto oro io adoro natale a don
natale
adoro questo per il make up natalizio
sarà fondamentale tenetevi pronti e poi
abbiamo un'altra caramella dei lidi di
polar crema viso crema mani e balsamo
labbra concentrato gli estratti di bakka
selvatica
garantiscono bellezza ancestrale delle
femmine lapponi ok forse ho sbagliato
qualcosa proseguiamo non manca poco a
polar crema rivitalizzante all'alga
boreale io adoro questi ingredienti così
poco scontati così poco mainstream no
vabbè ha un profumo meraviglioso è
veramente lascia la pelle liscia loro
poi siamo proprio agli ultimi gli altri
pacchetti rimasti a questa è una
spazzola ragazzi voi dovete sapere che
c'è in casa mia
il dramma per l'espansione perché ho
tipo 45 spazzole e salvatore le usa fu
te e io è una cosa che odio perché io ho
le mie spazzole tu hai detto e spazzole
lui ai capelli scuri io e capelli
castani pd si vede subito quando le
usano lui e mi dà fastidio perché ce ne
sono 4 o una e tu a una mia e le altre
sono mie
e invece no lui le usa tutte quindi
questa spazzola verrà messa sotto chiave
e oro e oro ragazzi e oro bianco oro non
è una pazza
la spazzola e così chissà cosa perfetto
rilassa
facciamo insieme se la metto lì così
senatore anche se siete contro una
spazzola lo capisci tu con spazio no e
allora finalmente marina ha uno scarso
la sua siamo arrivati alla fine ragazzi
allora proseguiamo con questo primer oil
free hourglass base minerale non grassa
adoro io adoro i primer però
effettivamente spesso tendono a
diventare cioè come base trucco un po
oleosi alcuni invece questo qua dice che
o il free quindi per la mia pelle mista
è perfetto vediamo facciamo un po di
pump fino a quando ecco lo vediamo la
texture hanno messo un po tanto e setosi
simo e lascia la pelle veramente super
super setosa
ed effettivamente si secca subito non
lascia lo l'odioso poi cast di io amo
kat von d suoi prodotti sono top usol
eyeliner questo è un altro eyeliner non
è quello che ho io quello che ho io e ti
può pennarello perché io di solito
solitamente uso quelli lì questo qua
invece il classico credo si però invece
del pennellino c'è del come si dice il
pennellino morbido a un po tutte melino
rigido che però è molto flessibile da
provare
non capisco come fa poi a fare la punta
proveremo vabbè comunque il prodotto in
sella eyeliner e pop e tiene per giorni
la questione fondamentale adesso è dove
infilerò tutti questi prodotti perché
come sapete vi metto qua il link della
mia beauty collection o quattro mensola
in bagno e sono full io vi saluto mi
mando un bacione enorme grazie per aver
visto questo video
nonostante ciò che non ti di voi magari
mi odieranno ma ne abbiamo già parlato
vi terrò aggiornati con le storie magari
con altri video sui nuovi prodotti sulle
novità natalizi eccetera eccetera viste
ragionati su questi prodotti che proverò
perché ora gli o provassero così sulla
mano ti mando un bacio enorme vi adoro e
ci vediamo nel prossimo vedrà
[Musica]